from the treatment of migrants to
freedom of expression to anti-terror
laws our standards of human rights
across Europe slipping this week on
conflict zone my guest in Vienna is
Michael of loyalty director of the EU
Agency for fundamental rights does he
believe Europe is doing all it can to
protect human rights
[Music]
michael--ah flirty welcome to in
conflict zone in a recent report the
agency has said that civil society is
under threat across the block the report
paints a portrait picture of the state
of fundamental rights within the
European Union it's a mixed picture it's
a picture of what's working and what's
not working we have to stay very
vigilant in Europe just like everywhere
else in the world to protect the
incredible institutions we develop a
second world war as everywhere in the
world our foundation the idea of the
European Union Human Rights democracy
and it's not getting better it's
changing we have some improvement it's a
very diplomatic world changing to good
or changing to the bad change to the
good in some places but right I am very
concerned about the situation of human
rights in Europe today we have a lot to
do across so many issues so many groups
migrants older people had the disabled
does a huge program of work to be done
but match the challenges with the
achievements but you have said that
quote 2017 was not a great year in terms
of respect of protection and the
promotion of human and fundamental
rights not a great year that's an
understatement
now I agree it was it was a very very
challenging time it remains a
challenging time take the migration
crisis it's still a crisis we started
not a crisis because of the migration it
is the crisis of democracy in the Member
States of Europe it's a crisis of
migration policy in other words I
largely agree with you it's about a
failure to show solidarity tourists to
share the responsibility across member
states
it's about failure to get the basics in
place in so many places we've been
following the story very closely for the
last two years and yes have been some
achievements but in the bigger picture
we're not there yet and in some ways
were worse off at this fortress of
Europe it has less doors than it had
previously during the speech in Dublin
at the Institute of International and
European affairs you suggested that the
European Human Rights Project
under threat frankly you are accusing
your own men estates that's correct
I'm saying that we have a threat because
of unacceptable levels of abuse and a
Riesling of pulling away from the
commitments in too many places and on
top of that a lack of conviction in
large parts of our citizens that human
rights are important for them and not
just for others so the very big project
of work but I think we know where we
need to go so let's look at the European
political map some examples Austria
Hungary Poland Islamophobia
anti-semitism hate speech again
minorities they have become everyday
practice in these countries I don't I
don't dispute with you that we have
really serious and growing problems and
it's the job of my agency to get the
data about those problems out there in
the public domain the actual experience
of Muslims in Europe the actual
experience of Jews in Europe put that in
front of the policy makers and decision
makers and then challenge them but
delivered on the human rights committee
the problem and not the solution in some
countries it's not that simple
and there's an enormous diversity of of
willingness to make for better societies
but it's not just the policymakers the
politicians who make our societies it's
also about civil society it's also about
the faith groups it's the citizens
themselves and a large part of our work
is to engage with them and to convince
them that this is something worth
fighting for
yeah I repeat my question in some
countries are the government's the
problem or the solution like Poland for
example I just wouldn't put it that
simply in some countries we've got far
more serious problems than others but it
ranges across all human rights that who
is responsible for these problems the
government some even of the head of the
governments are a part of the movements
of the right radical movements and this
is something afterwards were to which is
coming back and nobody would have
believed that this could be and it is
yeah but the great difference today is
that we have strong international human
rights standards by which we can and
must hold these people to occur
I'm worried that there's a lot of houts
hate speech out there that goes
unchallenged and unprosecuted that's
unacceptable and so a large part of our
work is demanding that the laws in place
which we did not have in place at the
time of the Second World War are
complied with but we are getting more
convenient with this since years
all of these hate speeches I'm not
anymore coming from the streets these
hate speeches are coming from presidents
from governments from politicians look
at the European Union the European Union
is also one of the reasons where we are
listening to hate speeches and this
wouldn't be possible before it is new
mm-hmm well legitimize yeah I also look
at the European Union which is doing a
good job of taking hate speech offline
which is pushing back and we've seen
some improvements in this regard in the
last few months I'm not discouraged at
all I see a long way ahead it's a
difficult it's going to be a difficult
pathway but I think in the end we'll get
there with the commitment of young
people in our societies the resilience
of civil society at the increasing
convergence of faith communities to do
something meaningful to challenge that
you are optimistic that's your job but
let's be realistic
again let's have a look in Poland let's
have a look in Hungary let's have a look
in France let's have a look even in
Germany a very successful growth of
parties who are anti-democratic a part
of their rhetoric is the headline hate
discrimination of minority sexual matter
discrimination racial discrimination
religious discrimination these people
partly are working with you they are
sitting in the European Parliament but
they are also sitting in all other
institutions in Europe well our job is
to uphold and demand respect for the
system of human rights we do that we're
putting evidence out there in the public
domain
tackling the fake news which in large
part informs some of the phenomena
you're describing getting the data out
there for the
actual situation no Muslims don't bring
sexual violence into Europe we have our
own problem
for example know the recent migration
crisis did not bring anti-semitism a
better Europe
that's long-standing currently wouldn't
be never about the Belarusian soon
before those annotations in Hungary are
saying that the Muslims are bringing the
problems well to the extent that's being
said we're pushing back against that
with the hard data but isn't it
hypocrite that such an organization who
is fighting against the racism is being
paid by countries like Poland and
Hungary where these governments are
responsible that your work is increasing
okay we're an agency of the European
Union which means we're somewhat
separate for them this is from the
decision-making institutions we're also
independent I think we're very safely
positioned to do our job with integrity
and and and it's a hell of a job to do
and it's badly needed right now more
than ever and data to take your own
words which EU Member State is
respecting human rights the least these
days I'm not gonna answer that question
because I don't think it's helpful we
see where forever is such an information
not helpful because we're forever
scanning the horizon of 28 questions to
all your research yes
which EU Member State is respecting
human rights the least these days you
can also mention two or three but it is
an information which is very important
ok but the response that gives you is
that it's neither helpful nor useful to
name a particular country because there
are problems everywhere and human rights
is not just about civil rights and
political rights it's also about social
and economic rights and when you see it
broadly understood like that the
problems are everywhere
there's no worse and by the way there's
no best either there's serious efforts
let's talk about these countries were
you have a lot of problems where you
feel that you are worried which are
these countries well certainly
undoubtedly we're concerned about the
situation in Poland and in Hungary and a
number of other states I visit those
countries that whenever I have the
opportunity I'd meet with the government
I meet with civil society I offer the
tools and the experience of this agency
to assist
them engaging their problems and we see
some small progress in this area for
example I was in Hungary just a few
weeks ago and I was invited by the
government to send a team to the
so-called transit zones these are the
border points at the border crossing
points to see how a more human rights
respectful system could be put in place
those conversations are underway right
now but I that's exactly the way our
agency can make some small progress in
contributing to the challenges in such
places
you mentioned counterterrorism and
fundamental rights and you mentioned a
concern with legislation around security
laws endangering human rights
you mentioned Spain for instance yes
well certainly in terms of
counterterrorism we have an issue right
now we have a legitimate need for strong
security and we want to support that in
a way that's respectful of human rights
and doesn't compound the problems it's
attempting to solve and that this means
we have some challenging conversations
we need States to slow down what is the
challenge slowing down for instance at
taking proper care looking at the
unintended consequences of actions
making sure that the limits on human
rights and there must be limits on human
rights that they truly are necessary for
the purpose that's being sought to
achieve we're delivering research to
assist this exercise again you are
talking with the governments you explain
if the government's but the things are
not going on as you want them to go in
Spain the counterterrorism law was used
for example to jail artists one of the
most famous cases was the arrest of two
puppeteers who in a street performance
used a pen in basque that a judge ruled
to be an excuse for terrorism this seems
like a clear violation of the right of
free expression everything is argued
with counterterrorism sure well to
engage issues such as when you describe
which you find in a number of countries
we need the strong human rights legal
analysis to challenge the practices of
the state it's not necessarily just the
law it's how the law is applied take
profiling we all recognize that you've
got to make choices and policing of who
to stop on a street
profiling but profiling can be
respectful of Human Rights
or it can be discriminatory and in
violation of Human Rights and it's one
of the things our agency is doing is
developing tools for intelligence and
for police services so that they can
avoid exactly the types of situation you
gave in your example but nobody's really
intervening from the political level
nobody the terror law was used in Spain
let's have another example by the high
court now we are on the level of the
high court send 13 hip-hop artists to
jail for years for what they called
praise of terrorism in a song I mean
what's going on in the European Union in
a country like Spain people are in jail
because they sang welcome singing a song
yeah the most important thing right now
is to reignite passion about the Europe
of values we're not an economic Europe
where one founded in human rights and if
we can better embed that culture better
engage it with the with the policymakers
then exactly the types of situation
you're giving will be much rarer in the
future you're talking about poems we are
talking about Hungary we're talking
about Spain we've talked about other
countries and the research your comments
your papers are also described in
countries like Spain so what is the
judgment why is the judgment which is so
important if a person like you is
judging well I are you so shy well our
function really is to gather the data so
that the policymakers and the decision
and the judges the courts and elsewhere
can take the necessary action get the
data out there do the analysis make that
available it's a vital function because
as I said earlier if we base our
decision-making on fake news on false
news on myth we're going to end up
obviously with ridiculous out your
information are not fake news no
information are news so the question as
to what are you doing with this stuff is
better put to the decision who has been
just something with your information
ultimately a human rights body like ours
with only advisory functions she is only
as good as those who make this are you
giving you the comments
of the EU member-states the EU
institutions so but you understand the
paradox you understand the problem you
are bringing in information to countries
which you are criticizing and you demand
that these countries will react but they
don't want to react they are very happy
as they are I'm not going to give Europe
a clean bill of health the problems are
serious that the issues are grave but I
do see small chinks of light I see small
improvements I gave an example of better
oversight of intelligence services here
we're having valuable conversations with
governments about how to put an
independent oversight that's achievement
I've seen refugees children locked in
cages when I first went to the hotspots
in Greece a couple of years ago they're
not in cages anymore that's an
improvement
it's the thousand small steps that are
making an important contribution to a
better European future I'll close Janka
said that what happened in Spain was an
internal affair also what you described
violation of human rights in a member
state can't be an internal affair can it
what human rights are not an internal
affair will sounds iweb so mr. Juncker
is wrong no I'm framing this in terms of
human rights and by that I mean that
Spain and all the other EU member states
are bound to human rights commitments
which transcend the state and and and
it's very important that have that the
issues of human rights are severe
violation rights in a Member State if
this an internal affair or not it
depends on the context for purposes of
the EU and how its structured it may
well be an accurate statement but for
purposes of human rights compliance no
it raises issues and international human
rights law so let's look at another
important country France the French
emergency law has been replaced with the
anti-terror law the new legislation
which went into effect last October give
security forces the authority to shut
places of worship without warrants that
means without actual proof religious
freedom is one of the most important
principles of modern humanist societies
how did this go hand-in-hand I think
it's very important to speak with
religious communities about that because
again it's you it's not necessarily the
law that's the problem
it's the application of the law and we
need to speak to them and listen to the
extent to which there are practices that
they consider are violations of their
rights and and in that way we form a
consensus about the artistry of the
government of the parliaments who are
deciding these restrictions yeah but I I
once ran a Human Rights Commission in an
EU Member State and I was I was struck
by the extent to which it's not the face
of the law that's a problem it's the way
in which it's applied and the manner of
which it which its applied can violate a
right as easily as we're respectful of
the right that's why it's important to
generate the evidence figure out what
the principles that apply in evidence
look like in reality of the state of law
we cannot make decisions without the
hard data but what the situation is and
how it impacts affected community but
you can arrest people today in France if
they seems to be a terrorist also
without warrants you can mm-hmm the law
is allow Eavis okay and then but in
terms of a question what are you are
asking me to respond to what is your
reaction on there well my reaction is as
I say the the the our job is to advise
the EU so that the actions of the states
be that the laws are the application of
the laws as human rights compliant but
we're not some overall judge we don't
have that capacity we're not set up in
that manner can somebody be neutral
being an advocate for Human Rights no I
were searching not neutral neutrality is
typically taking the side of an
oppressor in the context of human rights
I I want to quote again you your report
from January says about Hungary in
Hungary there were civil society reports
that public officials continue to use
libel and defamation laws to silence
criticism from citizens and journalists
what are the consequences after this
report something changed well we're
making sure that the debates get
triggered around Europe on the basis of
that report there was a discussion
yesterday in the European part
in which the report was cited
extensively we're triggering
conversations about the report in
Budapest in other capitals by that means
we give civil society the tools for it
to push back against unacceptable
practices and we're providing the basis
the knowledge base as I mentioned
earlier for other states and for those
with influence and to engage the
unacceptable we immediately there are
countries you don't have the freedom of
speech as it has to be and we are
accusing for example countries like
Turkey mm-hmm what is the difference
well we have to be just as hard on
ourselves as we do with any other state
outside the European Union and again as
I say that's that's it that's the job
for the entire of the European political
community and not just for a single
agency which is providing the data and
the evidence as so that those hard words
can be spoken and I see those hard words
spoken increasingly again is the
situation getting better or not at the
moment we're in a bad situation but I do
see chinks of light towards the future
why why because I see more and more
governments in this European Union or
even on the top or the junior partner
parties which are openly openly
discriminating racists nationalists
right-wing parties from where is your
optimism coming it's coming from many
places for example we're getting more
serious about promoting economic
equality and so-called socio-economic
rights a dimension of human rights we
haven't had a chance to speak much of in
this conversation I see it in in young
people it could sound condescending but
genuinely from traveling around Europe
meeting with youth groups and with
children's groups
I see solutions being offered I see a
willingness to to to go over the
divisions - and I see more and more
government power which are representing
all these issues we are talking about
certainly there are populist tendencies
out there against which we have to push
very hard but we can do that as I said
earlier by shattering myth by dispelling
these crazy stories on the basis of
which people are being rallied by
delivering for people bed
tackling inequality by showing that we
can have fair societies based on human
rights and there are so many other
dimensions by the way also easy and as I
said I think earlier in faith
communities a greater desire to come
together and to resist at these these
tendons that Islamophobia is today in
several countries a declaration of
governments is an official declaration
certainly hatred against Muslims and
patterns of discrimination as we see
from our surveys are very worrying
something like 40% how can a country
still be a member in the unit in the
European Union if a country is not
anymore respecting human and fundamental
rights how does this go on what is the
message that such a country is still
representing the fundamental idea of
human rights okay well first human
rights is much broader than the framing
of our discussion it's also about
putting food on the table delivering
health care we have to make broad
assessments about human rights
compliance taking all those dimensions
into place that said I don't disagree
with you
we do need stronger mechanisms and tools
in Europe to hold states to account we
hold them to account before they enter
but once they're in the club it doesn't
work so well and that's an area that is
receiving attention right now in the
context of strengthening the rule of law
frameworks something words you just
mentioned that before let's look at the
migration issue in March 2016 the you
signed a deal with Turkey intended to
keep back the refugee flow Amnesty
International says turkey quote is not a
safe place for refugees struggling the
meat people's basic needs the Turkish
authorities are failing to ensure that
refugees and asylum seekers are able to
live in dignity human rights watch calls
it a problematical deal healthy you
abandoned its principles in order to
keep away refugees we have a great deal
to do we have to be a more welcoming
Europe and not for everybody but for
those who need international protection
once they get here and by the way
we ate people to get here in the
Mediterranean by a dramatic level of sea
rescues which i think is under
acknowledged but still we have too many
walls once they get here they have to be
treated with respect
we're still not there we still don't
have that respectful sharing of the
responsibility so this remains a very
grave issue of human rights it sounds
good it's not the reality of the
European Union today another country
which is resolving the influx of
refugees is Libya Human Rights Watch
said the EU has tried to prevent asylum
seekers and irregular migrants coming by
shifting responsibility for migration
control onto countries outside the U
borders notably Libya in ways that
expose people to human rights abuse do
you accept this blame I accept that a
much better job could be done of
honoring the human rights of people
trying to get into Europe that does not
mean letting every one of them in
reading and those individuals the
protectors and we know consciously that
these peoples are in Libya in a failed
state we agree that these people are
living in a failed state only with the
argument we don't want to have them in
Europe our Human Rights guarantees
extend to what we do outside Europe and
that has to be held in mind regardless
of whether it's turkey or Libya or any
other country it's the same degree of
attention for the basic human rights and
dignity of those people but then as I
say I really want to insist once they
get here we have to do a better job of
protecting their human rights that is no
less important which countries are in
your mind when you say something like
that what I have in mind actually is the
intolerable burden we've placed on
Greece and Italy we've left them to deal
with this in a manner of which is is is
is impossible they've and where all of
Europe was needed to resolve the problem
including towards respectfully receiving
a fair number of people from Greece and
Italy which has still not taken place
that worries me greatly since this
agency has come into existence
nothing has improved in the contrary
human rights have deteriorated no I
wouldn't accept that at all since these
agencies come into existence we have
adopted in Europe a Charter of
Fundamental Rights which
hard-wired protection of human rights
into policymaking and I see that on a
day to day basis how the outcome is
better because of the charter since this
agency came into existence
we have evidence on the situation in
Europe of a quality that you'll find
nowhere else in Europe we know about the
incidence of violence against women
because of the service we've done the
incidence of anti-semitism the instances
of Islamophobia and more if I may finish
we have also seen how that data has fed
into better policies so I understand we
know more but the situation didn't could
get better Michael Flaherty thank you
for being on conflict zone it was a
pleasure thank you very much
[Music]
you